cher journal
[Musique]
elle c'est moi lui c'est le garçon que
j'aime bien qu'ils m'aiment bien mais
qui a une copine qu'il n'ose pas quitté
ensemble nous n'irons pas nouvelle à des
dans les rues de montréal
nous n'irons pas non plus nous prendre
en photo devant la tour de pise en homo
quand des gens qui se moquent des gens
qui font semblant de la soutenir
nous n'irons pas voir les toiles de
jackson pollock au moma et il ne dira
pas qu'il faisait la même chose à cinq
ans et je ne m'énerverai pas en disant
qu'il ne comprend vraiment rien à rien
nous n'irons pas avoir de bons films qui
nous inspire ni même des navets qui nous
font dire que c'est fou de financer des
choses pareilles nous ne ferons pas rien
ensemble en rêvant à tout ce que nous
pourrions faire nous nous traverserons
pas l'amérique pour se poster vintage et
collector qu'on ne trouve que dans cette
toute petite boutique qui aurait fermé
deux ans auparavant et nous n'arriverons
pas et nous ne raconterons pas cette
anecdote à tout le monde nous n'irons
pas regarder les maisons que nous
aurions acheter si nous avions été riche
nous ne nous disputerons pas sur le
choix du prénom de l'enfant que nous
n'aurons pas et nous ne nous livrons
certainement pas à 8 heures le dimanche
matin pour l'emmener au foot et le voir
marquer contre son camp et lui dire que
ce n'est pas grave mon amour tu as mis
un but c'est le plus important
nous ne nous décevront pas et nous ne
nous déchireront pas tout simplement
parce que nous ne serons pas
alors voilà on a tourné qu'une mauvaise
bande annonce de notre histoire
elle ne rend pas tellement justice au
scénario qui semblait plutôt prometteur
c'est dommage il y avait du potentiel
oh la la c'est faux de financer des
films paris